Hello Nori. Do you like some apple? How about some burger? I'm going to school now.
I'm going to school now. Do you like school? Can you roll around? No. Can you do a little jump?
You don't want a hug.
Thank you Nori. How about can you turn on some story for me?
In a country across many seas, long, long ago, there was born a baby princess. Her parents,
a king and a queen had waited many lonely years for a child and when she
arrived they were beside themselves with joy how about gay some podcast yeah I
would like to listen to some podcast little adventurers welcome to nature's
wonders with Lily I'm Lily the forest ranger's daughter and I'm so excited to
take you on a magical journey through the forest today our special guest is
Julia the amazing talking owl hi Julia today we're discovering the secrets of the forest
we'll learn all about what the trees and animals have to say are you ready Julia to share the
whispering wonders of the forest with us let's start with what do trees talk about in the forest
I'm so ready trees have so much to say. Thank you, Nori